hello and welcome to another chess
openings explained I'm your host
Jonathan trance and this is the show
where we take viewer submissions from
YouTube so this week the overwhelmingly
popular opening that people wanted to
see was the English people have been
asking for this for a long time so here
it is we're going to take a look at it
so we'll just quickly look we'll put it
up here on the board so the move see for
this is a the English opening it's you
know it's very popular with our
Grandmaster that's here right now yes or
Sara Juan so maybe even watching his
videos and you've been looking at you
know some of his games and okay when you
see this move you typically think of a
very positional game but it's such a
flexible move you're not putting a pawn
in the center you're not playing efore
you're not playing d4 at least not
immediately you're instead going for a
LightSquared strategy you're taking
control of d5 early on okay so we do
have a Monday crowd here today so I'm
talking to you at home you're the only
one in the audience right now it's very
flexible opening which means a lot of
people both both positional very solid
players they like to play you know the
English also really aggressive players
we'll see a game Nakamura he usually has
a typically aggressive style we'll look
at one of his games and okay it's it's a
such an opening where theory isn't the
most important thing it's going to be
more about understanding the ideas and
the reasons behind certain moves so it's
it's not really for those people that
want to memorize theory so perhaps
that's an appeal to you if you want
something you don't need to study you
just need to learn some of the key ideas
then this is the right opening for you a
Michael and okay so maybe that also
could be a be a turn-off to maybe you
like studying openings where you can
memorize lines in which case you should
be looking at some and we'll try to look
at some of the theoretical lines now the
most logical move in this position and
whenever I like to study an opening for
the first time I like to
start what happens if both players just
make the most logical moves follow the
traditional classical rules what will
happen so the most logical move since
white didn't directly context the center
black Ken you can play the move e5 so
with this move he's making you know the
move d4 unappealing and he's taking some
control over the center now there's
there is actually kind of a debate
already between people that I'd like to
play the English and that's what to do
on move to the most logical move is just
develop a knight how could that be wrong
but another very popular move is the
move g3 and what it is probably going to
end up playing both of these moves
anyway so it does make some sense to us
to play them in it understanding the
move order here is kind of important
he's going for a LightSquared strategy
so he's taking control over some of
these light squares in the center and
he's going to use his pieces to contest
those squares so it makes sense to put
the bishop on g2 g3 is considered to be
slightly more flexible than the Knight
to c3 lines one of the reasons is
there's a couple side lines that black
can play now that he couldn't play if
you had played g3 chief among them is
probably Bishop to b4 and this has a
very popular reputation and there's a
couple things you can do you can just
defend your night you can play g3 or yet
play g3 and let them take your knight
and you'll take back with one of these
pawns those things are fine also
interesting is the move Knight to d5
where against all bishop retreats and
there's about three possible bishop
retreats that you could you can imagine
what gets a decent position but it's
something you you might want to avoid
it's of all the sidelines it's not a
very bad one for black so if you're
considering this for black you might
want to take a look at that because
those are indeed interesting so for the
most part today we're going to look at
the move g3 and I have two recent games
that we're going to see but first we're
going to check out a classic game and
this is the game between a Mikhail
Botvinnik in portage lejos
here we go it's enough of that yeah
alright so here we go with our game
it starts with c4 c5 and today we're
going to look this game was played in
1968 so back then this was the most
common move so it's that's what we have
today and we're going to check out lines
in which black just plays for an
immediate d5 so what's going to happen
is it's going to be a Sicilian with
reversed colors so White's going to
develop his pieces Knight to f3 g3
Bishop g2 and we're going to look at the
lines where black plays the move d5 so
this will strike you as a Sicilian in
Reverse it's an accelerated dragon only
white is up a tempo here so you might
think that's a that's a big plus maybe
it's you know should be some huge
advantage but this is very playable for
black because even though you got the
extra right what you your opponent has
an extra tempo yeah you won't play as
aggressively for an advantage when white
plays the Sicilian he's trying to get
some big advantage out of the opening
but when you play it a tempo down you're
not going to do that you're going to
play a little more conservative and
you're not going to be as aggressive and
you're still going to get a decent
position in this line ok so we know
where the bishops going and all right so
this move is is not as popular today
usually black will just develop Knights
and once these Knights are developed the
main move is actually to play Knight to
b6 and we'll see why in just a second
here but Bishop e6 was played so white
attacks in the center black defends
white castles and now black retreated so
he was going to retreat anyway so he
could have done it before and then left
it unknown where this Bishop that
started here was going to go into the
game it's probably going to go to e6
anyway but it's a little bit more
flexible just to put the knight on B 6
now you're not going to be able to do a
Yugoslavia to slow
even a move like Bishop to e7 is going
to be a little bit too slow here because
now white is castled
and he's up a tempo here so he has time
to get the move d4 in and this is known
to be very good for for white he's going
to get a very pleasant advantage out of
the opening here for example if we take
all right we take back with a knight
we're threatening to inflict double
pawns
we might be able to get his Bishop so
black will we'll take we'll take back
now all right so we got threats all over
the place so he's got to do something so
he can take our Knight and we'll we'll
take back notice that this is going to
fail the knight gets out with check and
then the rook moves to safety so okay so
we'll take here and now if he castles
you know because we are attacking this
pawn still so he castles predicts is
pawn we went upon so there's gonna be
some position like this and now okay
blacks gonna have some compensation he's
going to get some pressure going on the
Queen side but it shouldn't be enough so
white what should have sufficient
compensation for a pawn he should be
doing quite well so that's why in
general in this position they play
Knight to b6 okay in d3 the most normal
looking move is actually a bit outdated
now so we'll see in more modern games
people prefer the move a3 and we'll even
see a game today where people prefer
rook to b1 the idea behind a3 is you
play a 3 B 4 and the bishops going to go
on b2 and this is immediately going to
put a lot of pressure in the center and
you're trying to force a concession from
black you want them to play the move f6
so in this game okay d3 was played this
game i'm not showing you because it's
the latest theory mostly because it was
just a very nice played game by white
and so we'll we'll check that out all
right so a3 was played anyway he's going
to play the move b4 and now we're going
to look in our next game at when black
just castles which is probably his best
move allowing white to play the move b4
but in this encounter black decided I'm
going to stop you from playing b4 and he
takes time to play the move a5
this does give up some light squares on
the queenside
and that's key to our strategy as white
so it's not as commonly played anymore
now they normally wait for a pond to end
up on b4 and only then will they
sometimes strike with a move like a 5
but ok a 5 was played and now one of the
many plans is to start to take control
over c5 so the bishops attacking c5 you
can imagine a rip coming to c1 you can
imagine the knight maneuvering over to
c5 where it'll have a lot of pressure on
blacks position and this is what you can
kind of expect so black castles and ok
look
rook rook c1 is just a normal move it's
probably what I would have played in
this position but it wasn't played in
the game instead Knight to a4 okay so
he's looking at the c5 square he's going
to put either a knight or a bishop there
and black probably shouldn't take which
is what happened in the game because
he's helping bring the Queen to a better
square he should probably prefer
something like Knight to d5 where okay
we don't want to give up this guy so
we'll probably go back and alright after
a move like like d6 and we we trade it's
not obvious what this guy is doing over
here so he's gonna have to move back
this is truly a weakness and that's kind
of going to be that in most positions
that's going to be the plan for white
one of its key Trump's here is the C
file so he's going to try to load up his
rooks on on the C file in almost every
line here and he's going to take aim at
some of the black pawns here okay but he
traded in the game and so the Queen
comes in now she's looking at going to
some pretty nice squares where she's
going to have some some pressure on the
Queen side and black decides all right
I'm trying to stop you from doing
another maneuver that would be very
typical you might be thinking of
bringing your night to c2 and jumping
into some of these like squares well if
you did that then I'd be able to trade
the bishops that's his big point he
wants to trade the bishop on g2 it's one
of white strongest pieces so well we'll
see what really happened so he played
here now he starts to load up on the C
file
and all right you could start with the
other rook but okay he decided to go
with with rook F to c1
okay rook e8 blacks plan is he's just
going to put his uh his his Bishop back
his rooks going to add some extra
protection of his EEP on he's trying to
avoid playing a move like f6 like he
sometimes might have to do and on a very
good day he's playing in the movie for
but it's not going to happen in this
game he never gets the time so white
begins his plan black backs his Bishop
up and now we double on the C file and
now black made a horrible blunder but
it's a very instructive one so he should
try to find any other move than this he
played Knight to b8 and not surprisingly
he went backwards and that's the wrong
move so he's he's saying you can take
this but I have a trick and so it's kind
of cool white did he he went in for the
trick he fell for it which is important
blacks idea was all right I'm now I'm
attacking your queen and you're look so
has white fallen into a big trap well
this is nice what white did he he's
wooden your opponent this kind of has a
trap you realize okay he put his his
knight back because he's saying you
can't take it well you want to prove him
wrong you don't want to give his his
idea too much respect you want to say
you're saying I can't but I'm still
going to do it and I'm going to prove
that it's it is right and so in this
game he took so okay here we're about to
get to the the amazing part of the game
which is why I wanted to show this one
first so at home you might want to pause
your screen here for a second see if you
can find the next little combination and
see if you can you can figure out what
white played the next couple moves here
alright so he decided to take the
LightSquared Bishop which is essential
to his plan he's playing for a light
square dominance so he took the
night.the took the bishop so this is
very common to in this opening when they
you know you want to sacrifice an
exchange to get the light squared bishop
now this guy has a lot of potential
he's on this very wide-open diagonal so
a lot of good things can happen for
white you can often get a lot of
compensation just by giving up the
exchange now he didn't play this move if
you just put your knight here we take
your pawn we have two pawns for the
exchange which is sufficient
compensation but these bishops are
looking really nice
in particular the one on g2 there's this
is kind of the dream position for the
bishop
there's no pawns on the long diagonal so
he's just gonna you know have a great
Bishop for the rest of the game and okay
this guy's not gonna be so bad either
he's going to come to one of these nice
squares he's going to do something good
so in the game black took with a pawn
so again you might want to stop and try
to figure out what white did here you
can play a normal move okay rook b7
maybe this is what what black intended
and again white still has a lot of
compensation these pawns are not very
strong so this Bishop is quite nice but
he found an even better move so perhaps
you you found it at home if not it's
it's not an easy one to see he played
rooks takes f7 so wow he's really trying
to to get on this this long diagonal
here he's trying to he's trying to take
control of the light squares and he's
trying to see what will happen if the
King takes the rook in the game he
didn't take and for good reason if you
excuse me if you take now we'll get this
check in okay you're not going to want
to run to either of these these dark
squares because either way you go you're
at least losing a queen you know so
you're you're going to have to well okay
yeah you're going to have to like run
with your King and all right things are
not going to be pleasant for you again
you don't want to run to the dark square
because we got these sorts of things
okay this this looks really good you
know you're you're in a lot of trouble
here especially even if you go back
check and you're going to get into a
smothered mate here so very typical
smothered mate and there's there's not a
lot else you can do let's see you could
try to protect with with your rook
okay at least I'm at least winning this
probably if you ask your engine it'll
find some checkmate with some other move
like this but uh okay seeing that you
can you can fork the pieces is
sufficient to to refute that line so he
can't take the rook so he played the
move h6 a useful move now the knight
doesn't have g5 which is going to be one
of the the key squares in these lines so
now he probably can safely take the rook
because there's not going to be a knight
check so he moves his rook away and now
he's up to pawns for the exchange and he
still has the very pleasent bishop these
ponds are very weak and it's okay so
it's hard because it's hard to develop
your knight to anywhere useful because
anywhere you go you're going to drop
your C pawn so black attack the rook
alright so we gave this check the King
moved into the corner now again you're
going to want to pause your video and
ask yourself what white played here
because he plays another brilliant move
we have an audience now so if they know
they can they can shout it out all right
okay sure alright so he left his rook
they're hanging he played nine h4 he's
coming in to the g6 square here so all
right
black accepted the rook and now what's
going to happen well okay our queen has
this nice long diagonal so he gave this
check and now again a very nice move
this one's not as as tough to see but
maybe you can find it at home alright
Bishop to e4 setting-up discovered
threats so blacks in a lot of trouble
here all right he gets this Bishop out
what else can you do and now we have any
discovery we can move the knight
anywhere
he keeps the knight in the center of the
board check now if you go back let's see
both the both of these moves look really
good so you can do either fork okay this
looks this looks pretty nice
and then we take care check and then I'm
getting your queen so okay so that's not
good
so instead he played g6 he's trying to
give his King an escape square so will
he be able to run away well okay so we
get our first check-in and now pause
your video again because there's another
really nice move that was played here so
we'll give you a second to see if you
can you can find it and we have multiple
people in the audience so either one of
them could answer this and there's
certainly more than one good move here
but it's a prettiest and most incisive
Bishop takes h6 another excellent move
and it's nice when you have sort of a
masterpiece of a game like this when you
just every move is so pretty and here
are black gave it up so we'll try to
understand let's see so you can take our
bishop or you can you can try to run all
right if you if you take the bishop we
at least have this sort of a thing where
we're winning your Queen wherever your
king goes so that would that would be a
disaster
so you can't take the bishop in all
right it's obviously very unappealing
going anywhere else so okay you can try
you try one of these two squares and all
right so I mean it's so many so many
good moves this is this looks good man
yeah looks pretty good and you don't
want to walk into this discovery again
it's the same thing where you're losing
your queen so you might have to play
Queen takes Knight and you don't want to
do it all right running up doesn't look
very good either let's see so probably
here and you'll go you'll go somewhere
and I just I got to contain you
all right and yeah it's just it's not
looking good there we go so okay so for
these reasons you can't take in you you
can't not take so black had enough and
he gave it up so a very good instructive
game white got his rooks onto the sea
file his opponent dared him to take his
sieve pawn he accepted that and he he
really had you know complete domination
of the light squares the entire game he
even sacrificed a rook on the DF pawn so
I've never really seen that before it's
a really neat idea your rope can take an
f1 just to dominate the long diagonal
here so an excellent game so now we're
going to move on to some more recent
games and one of our viewers had said I
just checked it this morning I just
didn't intended to do it all from
White's perspective but Knight 11 you
said I want to see it something from
blacks perspective so I'm going to show
a good game from black playing the same
opening and it is kind of a warning to
white white makes a pretty big mistake
that's very common so I want to go over
that so we know exactly what not to do
when we're playing this opening the
player with white pieces in this game
gets the prize for the coolest name it's
a REITs reason ease reads NEETs so
that's a pretty cool name and now he was
playing karaoke encar y'all can
obviously is that 2700 super grandmaster
so he was able to win this game against
an opponent you've never heard of we're
going to flip the board because white
played so bad we're going to get them as
far away from us as possible so we're
going to look at this one from blacks
perspective for a change alright so
here's the beginning of our opening
let's see what was chosen in this game
this game started with Knight c3 another
very possible way and black just goes
right for the reverse Sicilian the e
pawn is a text so it's defended and
after g6
we get to move d5 so here we go again
this is our position from before well
fianchetto our Bishop flex immediate
plan is just to get developed in the
last game we saw like Bishop e6 that had
been played a little bit earlier but in
this case he just retreats the bishop he
knows he's going to
anyway so why not just get it out of the
way castles Bishop e7 and now White's
going to make a decision is he going to
play d3 is he going to play a three well
in this game he decided to go d3 okay
very sensible
so we Castle and now he's beginning his
plan so in the other game we saw black
play the move a5 and stop white from his
b4 idea but in this game car you can
just let some do it and you'll see why
in just a second he just develops his
bishop right okay and now with once
they've played before now you can play
the move a5 and so you have a lot of
pressure here and you're kind of coaxing
them to come in to the b v square and
you're you're trying to say okay well
now that that pawns there you're not
going to be able to put a knight on the
b 5 so that's going to be advantageous
to black but you might be thinking hey
this Knight is attacked and if this
Knight moves this pawn is going to be
hanging so all right so the first
question we should probably ask is well
what happens if black takes this pawn
black takes he's actually going to be in
a lot of trouble here the move to play
is Bishop to f6 a very nice diagonal
just an awesome Bishop so you don't have
any time to like retreat your knight
because you would take here check and
then you notice that this Knight is
hanging so that would be a big problem
so you might have to play a move like f4
and now White has a really nice move
Knight to b3 with a threat that you see
and a threat that you don't see you see
that your rook is attacked but what's
the threat that you don't see
so black actually has a threat that's
even greater than just taking the rook
so if you play you know move you just
save your rook you're going to you're
going to be shocked by by his next move
here and that's queen d4 check and the
knight is hanging so you want a piece so
or you'd have to defend against that
that's the greatest threat and alright
this looks kind of like a mess for Wyatt
he moved some of his pawns on the King
side here you want an exchange so so
that would be a big mistake but instead
he made another mistake probably you
should just bring your knight back to d2
or at least you know play rook b1 try to
take control here's a very important
light Square the B 3 square which is
kind of crucial to blacks plans a lot of
the time so the rook is often very good
on b1 because it controls b3 and all
right you might not want to trade the
Knights if you put play Knight d2 then
in the future you're going to play you
know III you're going to kick the night
away but he took the knight and this is
a is a big positional mistake and it
happens all the time with this pawn on
d4 now White's entire King side or yes
King side pawns are really cramped
you're never going to be able to move
your EEP on without creating even more
weaknesses because wherever it goes
we're going to take it and then your D
pawn is going to be weak also now
alright at some point we're going to
bring our rook over and we're going to
put pressure along the e file and now we
have a weakness that we can target
ok so immediately we're on your night so
the night went to a four all right the
last game we saw somebody take but that
only helps white bring his piece in we
notice this Bishop 2 is asserting some
pressure so black seeks to trade it off
this does however give white the
opportunity to a double black spawns so
that was taken and ok now is this how
bad is this well it's not so bad
white didn't crash through on the Queen
side he has no Queen side play which is
where he's trying to play obviously our
three on two is never going to be able
to create a
sir but we'll notice there is a weakness
on the queenside the blacken attack and
we'll check that out in just a second so
Bishop b2 and all right so black managed
to get rid of the English Bishop a real
big success for him and I have to check
all righty it improves his queen the
King drops back now a very nice move
obviously we can just take this pawn but
okay we wouldn't want to drop our deep
on here it's it's one of the strongest
pounds we've got so we found a really
good move not not too hard but if you
want to pause and just just find a nice
easy move here alright it's a it's a for
the plan is just go attack this weakness
and now you can't defend it so blacks
just going to go and he's going to take
your beep on and there's there's nothing
you can do about it so alright
it moves his Queen he's going to try to
use the C file this is kind of key to
his plan one of these rooks is going to
come over to the C file but now we do
have time to attack his pawn in comes a
rook we take the pawn now after this
move you might be thinking well wait a
minute is white you know getting back
into this okay this this rook looks
pretty good it's forking two of our
ponds but black has a good move here he
can just defend the most important pawn
and now tactically white can't take this
a pawn so we'll see if we can find it in
the audience see if you can find it at
home what uh what move would black play
here
you
hopefully you found it at home all right
Queen to b3 for King to pieces so this
would be big trouble for for white so
the a Ponton is immune we can't we can't
take it yet
so instead he attacks it again now we
could you know try to defend it somehow
but he comes up with another nice move
again
da pawn is immune in another position
here which is kind of cool
because now what will happen if we take
with the rook go ahead and see if you
can you can find it at home alright
b5 would trap the rook notice there
there's no escaping your rope just gets
trapped so again you can't take the pawn
alright so what gets everything he's got
going on the C file again we could
probably tactically leave our a pawn
hanging but okay decides all right now
is the time I'm just I'm going to defend
my pawn also this Queen might be
thinking okay at some point maybe I want
to swing over to the Kings side get a
King side attack going because you'll
notice it's really hard for white to get
his pieces over to the defense of his
King so at some point here he's going to
get serious about how is he going to you
know defend over there and notice okay
for the moment a3 is hanging so white
made a really sad move he brought his
rook back so off of the open file back
to they file okay and here black goes on
the add the Kings side h5 alright so
everybody is stuck over on the Queen
side let's try to get something going on
the Kings side and alright he didn't
want to allow black to make such moves
maybes going to play h4 h3 get some
pressure here you don't have your your
Bishop so alright so white played h4
himself
now you can probably do something really
crazy like g5 here but it wasn't played
the point is okay if you take I'm
playing h4 and all right you probably
don't want to let my my Queen in here at
some point but also it you can go a lot
slower as black you don't have to go
crazy do the computer lines because no
matter what you're going to do in this
pose
Bishan they're going to be better for a
long long time and we'll notice in this
game car yakin just moves around and
that's what you know all the best
grandmasters do they make a thousand
moves doing nothing just slowly
improving stuff and then they strike
when you least expect it so alright rook
e8 finally we got some pressure here
going on the epon so alright what
defends it a second time and now again
g5 is possible but rookie v was played
okay so now this rook has possibilities
sometimes if you do play move like g5
maybe the rook will be able to swing
over for an attack but maybe also it's
just going to go to d5 protect this pawn
for a third time so that some of our
pieces could move so our Queen could
move away from the defense of the pond
the bishop can move away and that's
indeed what happened so now this guy's
defended three times we can move some of
our other pieces so here we go first he
just slowly improves his King all right
and then there's a lot of lot of - and
throw he can obviously start thinking
about you know moves like just really
bringing his king and queen in but uh
but okay he went to the Queen side which
is also decent he's always gonna be
better what can do nothing you just sit
and you wait and you hope you never get
checkmated so we'll see we'll see if it
works alright so he defends his bishop
and now his pieces start to riemann over
the bishop you know it's on his way to
e5 he'll protect it from there and then
he's going to bring you know some of his
pieces back and he's going to get them
closer to the Kings side because well c5
is nice your block in the C file it is
time to start getting this guy over here
maybe you're thinking about some day
I'll take on g3 especially if my queen
could jump over there quickly that would
be a realistic sacrifice so he worried
maneuvered his bishop so now his bishop
has potential to sac on the Kings side
back comes the Queen and that white
really needs to play a move like King G
to stopping the Queen from ever making a
move like Queen h3 because once the
Queen gets to h3 there's going to be a
lot of potential for sacrifices black is
going to have a way to make inroads to
the to the king and okay this rook is
also going to be very fast
and sometimes helping a checkmating
attack and what you made a really big
blunder here rook c8 which just allowed
Queen h3 and the the sad part is you
can't even defend your pawns like this
because hopefully you see it at home the
Queen would make a very long retreat and
it would take your rook so all right so
there's nothing to be done about that so
you make some other move and now this
the sacrifice works so again there's no
there's no time to take this rook
because you're going to get checkmated
so that's a pretty pretty powerful
attack we got going on so instead he
took and now it's it's almost over here
check alright if you go this way you get
check mated immediately so he went the
other way though this is still very bad
and after Queen h4 he resigned all right
we can try to see the checkmate it's a
it's looking pretty good for these two
pieces so if the game continued maybe
King g2 and alright let's get let's get
this guy into the game now you have to
to pick a square this one is pretty easy
okay this is one one way to checkmate
let's see if we go the other way
mmm probably a lot of ways all right
this is looking pretty good alright
what's the fastest way so maybe we can
find the fastest way but okay but I mean
this something like this is going to be
checkmate in a few moves so there might
be faster but okay but with two heavy
pieces wide open and nobody to defend on
the Kings side you're going to get
checkmated here so yeah so the big
mistake in this game was a if we go back
a long ways here yeah
Knight takes d4 this was a very bad move
so this is something you really want to
avoid with the white pieces the pawn on
d4 is just too strong you get cramped on
the Kings side
it's really hard to defend you didn't
get any counterplay on the queenside
and okay black got to move around as
much as he wanted to put his pieces in
all the right places and then launched a
successful attack on the king so
hopefully we'll never play that move in
our in our games and pop something not
just in this opening it pops up in a
quite a lot of openings but now we're
going to move on to a very recent game
it was just played in the the last
millionaire tournament that we had in in
Vegas this year so this was a game
between Nakamura and America's youngest
Grandmaster sam-7 who last August 2014
yeah he got his is rating all the way up
to 2500 which was he already had his
three norms and he did that right here
in st. Louis so we're kind of proud of
that and we'll check out a game between
these two and they got to our opening
here we've seen all of these moves
okay so again most common things that
we've seen we've seen d3 we've talked a
little bit about a3 that's an idea to
here Nakamura played the third most
common is kind of a rare move but it's a
it's a nice one I quite like this idea
rook b1 he's going to try to play the
move b4 he's going to try to make this
work tactically without having to play
the move a3 which is a it's a really
nice idea because okay the rook is
usually good on b1 we've seen it in this
in this opening you know control some
some key squares like b3 so we'll see
what happens when we play this move so
he castled
and now b4 so all right this works
tactically there are two pieces
attacking our pond but you'll notice
sometimes we're going to deflect his
Knight away we'd be able to take a
central pawn so I mean taking with the
bishop is is kind of just right out
because well we would get two to trade
you know a side pawn for a central pawn
so that's a small achievement for us if
you just take the knight okay we take
your your bishop and you don't have
anything fancy like taking my knight
first because now I take here and
alright you're going to you're going to
end up with double pawns so this is not
going to be good this is just terrible
because
all right this guy is a monster and all
right our audience just doubled all
right got a lot higher rated I love it
so okay so this position would just just
be terrible so there's there's no way
you could take with the bishop you might
want to consider taking with the knight
again
okay this was a small strategic success
for white he gets to take a central pawn
trade it for a side pawn not that it's
you know going to be just super easy he
didn't get quite as much as he did in
the other line but all right this would
just be a nice small victory for white
so the most common move is to play a six
just prevent white from doing any ideas
he might have with b5 but all right in
this position Sam played kind of a
typical Sam 7 move he played the move
efore so he say you can have my e pawn
but only under my terms so now he when
he takes he could consider taking back
right away but this was his idea he's
getting some of his pieces out as
quickly as possible
so now there's a threat to the night and
all right
so you can't really move the knight
because of the pain here so white
voluntarily goes into a pin now he's
hoping for something like this this
would be nice for him because now he has
a little trick looks kind of like okay
the Queen's kind of trapped and if she
moves away we will get to take tonight
but we have this tiny trick check and
then now we pick up this Bishop and that
would get us out of our pin and solve a
lot of our problems
so instead Sam took with the bishop the
point being now this trick is
unavailable because we will to take back
with a queen and now the bishops
protected so we no longer have that
trick to get out of the pin instead
knock a place to move a three a very
useful move he's taken the B 4 square
away because as soon as the bishop
retreats somewhere black wood would
really love to get a knight in here and
attack the Queen because if the Queen
has to move okay it's gonna be hard to
defend the night so all right a very
very useful move a3 and now another nice
move here he would kind of like to to go
harass
this bishop but but okay he's kind of
worried about Knight to d4 that's a
pretty pretty serious threat here so III
now he's he's taking control over the d4
square so now I Sam understands Knight
h4 is coming and he prepared a retreat
for his bishop so that was his plan he's
trying to keep the pin and okay so this
is nice you have a pin but now Vacarro
has a really nice plan of trying to make
this bishop a really bad piece so at
home you might want to pause and think
about it for a second what's uh what's
the plan here for white because the plan
he comes up with is quite nice and it
begins oops
f4 the point is you're playing at five
and you're shutting the bishop out so
after removal I got five okay your you
know your your bishops not going to be a
good piece so Sam's contemplating giving
up the dark squared bishop for the
knight and winning a pawn
it's very risky and hákarl lets them
have the opportunity and Sam's not the
kind of person that likes to just you
know take upon and then try to defend
forever he's usually not going to accept
such a thing and he probably doesn't
want to give away his dark squared
bishop in such a position let's just
pretend we we win this pod well with the
dark squared bishop is gone yeah you're
you're up upon you have given my knight
access to c5 which will cause you some
headaches also I'm getting serious about
attacking your king
I'm bringing the rook to be to where
it's going to have a huge amount of
scope I'm bringing the rook to f4 maybe
I'll swing my other rook in at some
times okay maybe I'll be able to play a
move like f6
and my attack is gonna be very strong so
Sam recognized this and I he did not go
in for the the pawn instead he played
all right 95 okay so he's he's thinking
where's this where's this night going to
go and now uh alright we do we do have a
lot of pressure here we want to kick
that night away so okay so first he
develops with the tempo this was the
night tonight's point and then
ff6 so this is not a very pretty picture
so please put your camera's away that's
just okay strategically that's that's
just terrible
it's a horrible move to have to make so
he should have done anything but that
alright okay so here comes a spawn he's
going to kick this night away
if the night moves away then sometimes
you're going to have some some trouble
defending your beep on all right this
was this point the night is in time to
defend the a five square it also comes
with a tempo on the bishop this is an
excellent attacking piece so we really
don't want to give up our Bishop for no
reason so we get to come into d4 all
right very very nice square all right
and yeah he was thinking there might be
be some tactics involved with that a
five so he just prevented it himself and
now yeah now his pieces are just coming
alive there's a lot of serious problems
okay this Knight is looking at some very
serious squares and black is already in
a lot of trouble so yeah and this is
just kind of the problem all right he
has this really bad piece and now he's
going to start losing some material here
so he felt obliged to give up the bishop
there's other ways to lose material but
okay
you still have the same problems yeah so
I'm attacking all of your stuff he
decides to save the rook which makes
sense and he took the knight here you
don't have to do that you can just
immediately take the B pod and keep the
pieces on but it Carlos a very practical
player when he has a winning position
he's a he's thinking the more pieces I
trade the better it's going to be for me
because it's kind of like you're playing
without this Bishop over here so if I
keep trading everything eventually we're
going to get to some position where okay
I have one piece left and you're you
have one piece that'll never move so
trading pieces is it's good for him also
not trading pieces is good for him
because his pieces are really good so
alright not not necessary but practical
and now he goes ahead and he he grabs
the pond so he snatched up a pawn
alright he brings his his Bishop back
alright now it's just it's it's getting
hard to to move some of his stuff here
and okay White has a lot of plans you
know he's just going to like improve his
pieces bring all of his pieces into the
game so I wasn't joking here he comes
the Brooks coming in tonight is a or the
queen is about to jump into a three and
you actually have a cute move here so
you might want to pause it you see if
you can find what the computer thinks is
is the best move and it's the cutest so
perhaps you found it well you can
actually play a move like rook to d5 the
cue point is okay you can't take my rook
because you drop yours and now you're
you know you're in a huge amount of
trouble so I'll be okay that's it's game
over and then the other point is well
I'm just gonna go take your pond and all
right what are you gonna do about that
it's it's getting tough but he played
made a practical decision he decided all
right I'll trade the Queen's it does
come at the cost of some structural
weakness now okay black in on a very
good day have time to go and attack some
of these ponds but again if you just
keep trading pieces blacks going to be
ended up with just this guy left and all
the whites pieces are gonna be better
than that bishop
alright now he goes for this pawn and
white doesn't defend his pawn and this
is kind of something I like to teach to
all of my students you want to ignore
all of your opponent's threats you want
to find some way to create an even
greater threat then you know that what
they're what they're threatening so
white just calmly doubles up we got some
threats here our rook is rook is coming
in and all right blacks in a lot of
trouble it's funny he just went back
thinking that okay he has to go and
defend this rink if he takes this pawn
King f2 and now he's in a lot of trouble
you can be really greedy but now your
rook is just totally out of the picture
so some combination of these works
checks and you know the Knights nice
jumping in is just going to be kind of
crushing so if we give this check for
example the pawn here is a huge headache
for black because now it's it's like
impossible to guard your back rank so
and also you're not in time to not take
the pawn
because okay still the same thing I'm
getting you here with with some threats
so you got to really worry about your
back rank so I guess he realized it's
kind of silly you know he moved his rook
and then he moved to pack realizing okay
he has to go protect his back rank he
didn't even have time to take the pawn
so he admits that he he made a mistake
and now all right
let's kick this Knight again because the
knight doesn't have any we're good to go
he defended his back rank now the
Knights got to make a tough decision the
only safe squares are not very desirable
so the computer thinks the best move is
to put this guy in the corner because I
guess when he went to school he was
really bad and he sat in the corner a
lot now these guys do not make a good
impression because you had a lot of
pieces now that can't move so you're
going to be in huge trouble in a second
realizing that all right you put the
route the knight in the corner he's
never getting out you're playing without
two of your pieces he says well I got a
play Knight to c8 even if it's not the
best move I got to do that but okay now
you know maybe the Knights thinking
about coming in so he just stops that
rook on the seventh you never you never
coming in here and well it's it's really
hard to move if you're black so attack
the bishop of course we're not going to
let you take our bishop and again I mean
your Knights not doing anything he's not
coming to these squares
what has him under control he just
defends his his pawn for the moment at
some point you know we're gonna think
about bringing her Bishop in and kicking
the rook away but he gave this check
first and the point is in this position
it's really hard to move and it was so
hard to make a move in this position
that Sam resigned the threat of the
episode b7 is just crushing you can't
move any of your pieces
it's almost uggs win it's you know I
wouldn't want to make a legal move here
either because it's just you're just
getting getting crushed so an excellent
game by Hikaru the idea with rook b1
early on is a really excellent idea the
point is just to play b4 tactically and
all right he just showed a real nice
move f4 was really nice f4 f5 blocking
in one
the Bishop's for black and he went on to
win a really great game so that's one
idea of how to play the the English it's
how you can play against the other
reverse Sicilian so hopefully you
enjoyed please like subscribe send me
some feedback maybe I'll pick your
opening next week thanks a lot